we should aim to reduce toil via
automation whenever possible
today i'm going to show you how to
automate the creation of monitoring
dashboards
this is the stackdoctor dashboards are
not a replacement for well-defined slos
alerting or good observability
they're widely used by many involved in
service reliability
and there are must-have capability in
any monitoring setup the first question
you should ask when setting up a
dashboard is what should be on the
dashboard
thankfully the answer to that has been
well documented in the monitoring
distributed systems chapter in the sre
book
if you have nothing else start with the
golden signals traffic
errors latency and saturation i'll go
over each one
let's take services running in gke and
managed by the istio service mesh
as an example we've covered using istio
with cloud monitoring and the excellent
telemetry provides in the past
today we're going to focus on using some
of the key metrics it provides about
traffic errors and latency for our
service
here's an example dashboard showing all
three the first golden signal is traffic
essentially a measure of how much user
activity the service is responding to
thankfully istio provides this natively
for every service in the mesh
the metric is called server request
count and the first chart in my
dashboard
request rates by service uses that
metric and groups the results by the
destination service name label
the next chart errors by service uses
the same metric and grouping options
the only difference is that the data is
then filtered to only count requests
or the response code is not 200. note
that this is a rough approach as it does
include
300 redirects and 400 errors which are
often the result of misconfigured or
misbehaving clients
the last chart again uses an istio
metric this time it's
server response latencies grouped by
destination service name
and using the 99th percentile
aggregation i'm not filtering out errors
for this one
though it might be a good idea if you
want to better understand how long it
takes to return errors and successes
separately creating such a dashboard
manually is not difficult assuming that
the data is available but it is toil
that should be automated if possible
with the release of the dashboards api
it now is you can also use the api to
for example copy dashboards between
workspaces to create additional
standardization via automation
let's take a look at how we can use the
api to create this dashboard
the general idea is pretty
straightforward we simply call the
project's dashboards create method
passing a dashboard's object which
contains a name description
and a set of widget objects that specify
the charts themselves here's the json
definition for the request race chart
we'll put the links to the blog post
where we can see the details below
i've created this manually but you can
use the api explorer to create your own
baseline and simply populate it with
parameters
note that the filter specifies the
resource and metric
this is also where you would specify for
example the cluster name service name or
other attributes if needed i use the
default aligner and the sum reducer
to simply total up the requests and
group them by the destination service
name metric label
to create the dashboard itself we
specify it as a grid layout
with the number of columns we want and
then define the charts as widgets
we then pass this in the body of the
request to the api
and here we are our dashboard is created
and ready to use
we're working on the features to make
the api even more useful
including enabling through the gcloud
command line also contributors are
discussing and planning the terraform
module for the monitoring dashboard api
in github but you can and should get
started with dashboard automation today
thanks for watching come back next time
this is the stackdoctor
stay healthy out there
you